hey guys in this video we're going to
show you how to make another fat bomb
this is just a chocolate fat bomb got
your cocoa coconut oil little vanilla I
actually forget what else is in there
but it's really basic ingredients super
simple you can make them in cookie our
candy molds which I do I go to the craft
store and buy gobs of candy molds are so
easy do not put them in the dishwasher
wow these are good yeah pop them in the
freezer
these firm up in about 15 minutes keep
them in the fridge keep them in the
freezer and when do you eat fat bumps
with the meal right after the meal as
your dessert to allow you to go between
one meal to the next without snacking
okay just trying to eat the whole thing
dirt good yeah really good just do one
or two
okay per meal all right let's show you
how to make them okay
you